-[ German accent ] Danke schoen.
Danke schoen, Jimmy.
Let's get this party started.
Okay.
Here are the rules.
So, pay attention.
Two of you will be put on
your noise-canceling headphones.
Uber cool.
And then I will play a hot track
and your partners
will have to guess that song
just by acting out the title.
But here is
the tricky part, fam.
The whole time
you will be spinning
right round
like a record, baby.
That's right. Those giant
records will be rotating
so you won't always
be facing your partner.
Keep the charades
going because each song
is worth 1,000 points
and 99 luftballoons.
Okay, enough of the talk.
Let's play the game.
Now take your positions.
John and Craig, go ahead.
Put on your headphones.
Taraji and Quinta, you will be
doing the charades first.
-Okay.
-We'll begin the rotation.
You'll see.
-Oh!
-Hold on to your bratwurst.
Three, two, one. Go!
♪ Come on, baby ♪
♪ Let's do the twist ♪
-Twist, twisting!
-Yes!
-♪ Get up on the dance floor ♪
♪ Vogue, vogue ♪
-Oh, Madonna.
"Vogue," "Vogue."
-Right!
-♪ Drop it like it's hot ♪
♪ Drop it like it's hot,
drop it like it's hot ♪
-It's hot.
It's getting hot in here.
"Drop It Like It's Hot."
-Oh, he got that!
Come on.
Quinta, quick.
Do it fast.
You have to do it fast.
-Beyoncé.
-Come on.
-♪ I'm a genie in a bottle ♪
-"I Dream of Jeannie."
"Genie in a Bottle."
-Yes!
-♪ Hold me closer,
tiny dancer ♪
-Come on!
Get your Elton John out!
-Tiny?
"Tiny Dancer." "Tiny Dancer."
-Whoa! Whoa! I've never seen
anything like this.
-♪ All my friends... ♪
-Oh!
-Ride.
Ride that...
horse or a little pony.
Pony, ride the pony.
Ride the pony.
[ Buzzer ]
-♪ Everybody's gone surfin,
surfin' USA ♪
-Pony...
-Surfing.
I pledge allegi...
"Surfin' USA."
-♪ My pony ♪
-Ooh, that was good.
I see you.
-♪ My saddle... ♪
-What do you got?
-Taraji,
this is a family show.
-Shake that booty?
-"Ride My Pony."
-Oh, that's it.
Yeah, that's it --
great playing.
Wow!
Wow, you have the moves like
Jagger, myself.
-Oh, my God.
-Now let's play one more round.
Okay?
Taraji and Quinta, put down
those fabulous
noise-canceling headphones,
please.
All right, now.
Start the rotation.
Three, two, one. Go!
♪♪
-Oh, "Macarena," "Macarena."
-Quinta, got it.
-♪ Call me on the line ♪
"Call Me."
-Yes! Nice!
♪♪
-"Hotline," "Hotline,"
"Hotline."
-"Dirt Off Your Shoulder."
-Yes!
Oh, whoa, whoa, hey!
-♪ ...girlfriend got the butt,
tell her to shake it ♪
♪ Shake it, shake it ♪
Hug the babies!
-"Baby Got Back"?
"Baby Got Back"?
-Oh, you got it.
Wow!
-♪ Physical, physical ♪
♪ I wanna get physical ♪
♪ Let's get into physical ♪
-Oh, oh, oh, oh!
"I'm Too Sexy for My..."
"Sexy for My..."
-♪ Face-to-face,
out in the heat ♪
-"Don't Cry"?
Eye, dagger, eye.
"Eye of the Tiger."
"Eye of the Tiger"!
-♪ Oh, she's a brick...house ♪
-Come on! Quinta, quick.
Five seconds!
Four...three...
-"Brick House."
-Oh! Holy!
Holy schnitzel!
You put me into a trance
with the power of the dance.
Good job, everybody.